hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the first of
his meditations after discussing why it
is that we can doubt the senses and
everything that comes to us through the
senses Rene Descartes is going to try to
move further and find something that we
can be completely certain about a range
of truths that we can build upon as a
sure foundation and so first he tells us
that we can't in fact out what comes to
us through or from our senses that is
what we hear what we smell what we feel
what we taste why well because our
perceptions they can be airing we can
mistake you know something that looks
square for something that's actually
round at a distance there's all sorts of
ways we can get things wrong and of
course we could also be dreaming but the
curt points out that even when we're
dreaming if we think about the basic
components or building blocks of what it
is that we are dreaming the things that
we mistakenly assume that we're
perceiving they have to be based on what
he calls more simple and universal
things
those are going to be true or real it
could be that all the images that we're
getting are actually fake but at least
some sort of base level should be real
and the Kurt doesn't have this in front
of him of course as a possibility at the
time but you might think about the image
that you're seeing or hearing right now
and the fact that we live in this world
that is mediated through all these
digital interfaces because you know
analog stuff at least there's some sort
of similarity to what it is that is
being represented or portrayed although
the similarity can sometimes be you know
quite strange and it's hard to wrap our
heads around you know a visual
similarity we can get that quite easily
but how exactly are the grooves on a
record the sound that we're hearing
right that's a little bit different but
still there is a fairly close connection
compared to when we think about things
as they are in the digital world where
when it comes down to it the entire
thing is really a bunch of machine
language based on on-off switches and
logic operators arrayed in two
incredibly complex technology now at
this point at one point it was actually
quite simple and easy to follow now it's
a little bit tougher to wrap our head
around but we know that at least in
theory what's going on in our computers
and our technology and what's coming to
us through our visual images for example
is that bottom something mathematical
you might also think about the pixels in
your computer they have codes that are
again a matter of mathematics the music
that you hear the sounds of you hear
mathematics or at least mathematically
represent represent a table right
representable sorry so what then for
Descartes
would would constitute this you might
call it foundation or threshold below
which everything can be taken as being
real
he gives us a list corporeal nature
right the nature of bodily things
whatever it is that they actually happen
to be maybe it's Adams maybe it's
something else
depends on the kind of physics that you
have extension this is another broader
term that Descartes uses quite
frequently in his works to talk about
bodily things they have extension for
example this is an extended substance it
exists you know with certain dimensions
and here we can also talk about another
part of extension figure or shape right
this is the shape of a book this is the
shape of a tie this is the shape of a
hand with fingers and fingernails you
can go on and on and on right they each
of them has their own particular shape
you might think about my moustache and
beard as having a certain shape to them
which is actually composed of a whole
bunch of other little shapes all coming
together right or the shape of my eyes
you know hopefully spherical more or
less I actually found out that the
reason why I have the astigmatism that I
do is because my eyeballs are a little
bit more oval Lloyd than they ought to
be so we can go on and on with examples
of this quantity how long is something
he calls it you know quantity or
largeness grandeur in French again let's
take a book has a length width and depth
we can also talk about number how many
pages are in this book of des cartes
meditations actually quite a few given
that it also has the responses and the
objections those are all things that we
can say those really exist and then he
adds in there as well space you write
the space in which something is and time
Tom all right so each of those is
something that Descartes says that's
real at least whatever is happening
the level of the census maybe that is
how our minds put those things together
or we could be you know completely
mistaken about them maybe they're the
equivalent of like you know Miss firings
going on but all this lower-level stuff
that has to be that has to be real so he
makes a distinction then between two
different sets of Sciences and this is
very interesting because what we see
here is decart telling us that certain
Sciences can be brought into doubt and
given his project of calling everything
into doubt that can't possibly be called
into doubt that means that those
Sciences are in effect taken off the
table as possible things to appeal to so
what does he say says this is perhaps
you know why we we're not badly
concluding if we say that physics
astronomy medicine and all the other
sciences that depend on the
consideration of composite things are
actually very doubtful and uncertain
physics we can't really know if things
are the way physics is representing them
to us because we can't know if the
things are the way that we think that
they are medicine even more so biology
if biology existed at that at time as a
direct object of study all of those
things would fit into those sorts of
issues optics you know things that are
sort of dependent upon physics all of
them deal with with you know material
things composite things that are not at
the very bottom level so what deals with
things that are you could say at the
basis of all these others here take card
only names to disciplines he talks about
arithmetic which is the science of
number right and geometry and it's also
important to remember
that the Kurd is one of the people who
brought these together if you've heard
of Cartesian coordinates there's a
reason why they're called Cartesian he
is one of the people who saw the
connections between arithmetic and
geometry well then he brings up the
possibility of talking about other
similar Sciences what are they dealing
with that gives them a higher degree of
connection to reality they're dealing
with simple as he says and general
things things that are very simple in
general for very much so in the French
right so these are the the sciences that
are dealing with what's most simple most
general what else would we include in
there
I suppose logic which he talks about in
other places or perhaps we might include
metaphysics
if physics is doubtful then maybe
metaphysics is not quite so doubtful if
we're doing it right
Descartes would say so what is the
upshot of this these we can trust these
we can use as a basis this is why
because as he says these have something
that not everything necessarily but at
least something
Kalka shows which is certain and
indubitable and that seems to offer us
the prospect of finding at least some
basis for escaping doubt very soon after
that he's going to point out that even
these things could be called into doubt
but first we have to see this
fundamental distinction he thinks
between those things that we're getting
from our senses and which involve things
that we take in through our senses those
which we understand primarily through
the operation of reason and the
intellect although perhaps involving
some imagination as well and those would
include arithmetic in geometry if those
go then it seems were really at sea and
struggling with doubt so at least at one
point he holds these out as a promise
that maybe we do have something that we
we can take as a basis something that's
totally certain and indubitable
you